good to see you man how are you i'm good
carlos how you doing
good you know given your history as
actually
like tarzan i think a lot of people
might assume that you're just team kong
automatically is that a safe assumption
is that fair to say
um absolutely not my
personally going into the movie uh
i was very much team godzilla
uh not a fan of kong
um kong stole my girl
when i was 10 years old i had a massive
crush on jessica lang
after i saw tutsi and then i saw the
first kong movie i saw was
was the one from the 70s in which kong
has a crush on jessica lang yeah and
i it infuriated me that he tried to
steal my girl
so uh yeah i've had a beef with kong
ever since
so in this movie yeah so it's real like
you're digging real deep as an
actor to try and find it in you in this
movie to be like
i'm going to be on team kong on screen
it was
it was it was a struggle again because
of that animosity
i felt uh but then
after spending six months on set with
kong
getting to know him on
getting you know to see that he has a
softer side
that how he's connecting with gia the
little girl and
how he is longing for a family
longing for connection i was like all
right
i kind of like this guy now he's all
right
he's all right he grew on me and by the
end of it i was very much team kong
i like that i like the evolution and
that's that's part of like being open
as an actor you're like okay i'm going
to go along with this now i'm now i'm on
the team
i i had to i had to work hard work on
myself and my
my my my prejudice and and and and
not holding on to that grudge from from
when i was 10 years old and just letting
go
neither of us got jessica lange
i'm proud of you
if you could if you could write a sequel
and where it's like
godzilla versus kong versus blank like
who would you love to bring into this
universe like is it godzilla versus
congress justice league
is it godzilla versus kong vs harry
potter like who are we bringing in for
the next big bout
i don't i actually would like to take it
in a different direction i think
there's a lot of violence in this movie
and
they are beating each other badly
kong and godzilla so for the sequel out
i'd like it to be more of a romantic
comedy
between kong and godzilla
or if you don't want romance there maybe
just at least like a buddy movie or
like they a road trip they travel
together but where they just like really
get along
could be some love or not i'm open to
ideas but
no fighting just like with their pals
yeah i love the idea
the idea of them like on a road trip
across america
like stopping to find the best food like
if it's like a like it's one of those
like food adventure
shows that we watch we get to tune in
with them every single week
yeah yeah yeah like the trip with steve
coogan i don't know if you saw that
those movies but something like that
they're just like hanging out traveling
drinking wine together
like i gotta work on this pitch i gotta
work on the idea it's not quite there
yet um
so but for now let's you can watch and
fight for two hours but then
we'll we'll i'm open to ideas that's
beautiful i think as far as like
interconnected movie universes go that
might be the best direction
for this one i mean if you're on board
with that i'll do what i can do to kind
of like support you
i love it i love it because i think you
want to surprise the audience
and if it's another two hours of them
fighting each other it's like that's not
really surprising but if it's a
a romance or a a road trip of them just
drinking
contemplating life what's the purpose of
it all while drinking some
some chardonnay
we'll brainstorm we'll work on it but i
think it's we're on to
something there's an embryo or something
cool for kind of something quite
interesting here
yeah i love that dude we'll talk about
that later but for now i gotta go
thank you so much for your time man good
to see you all right we'll continue this
brainstorming session later